[Música]
economía en directo américa usted ha
visto plaza sésamo daniela si lo vio y
siempre chiquita lo vi bueno ahí están
las técnicas como dirían nuestros amigos
es años partido ahora voy a empezar con
reino unido porque hay vacantes
laborales y están en récords àngela
iniciamos con un dato la tasa de
desempleo bajó al 4,3 por ciento con
corte a septiembre los tres meses
terminados en ese mes este es un nivel
más bajo desde junio de 2020 en pleno
primer pico de la pandemia pero hay otro
dato muy paradójico raúl y es que las
vacantes tocaron un máximo histórico en
octubre hay 12 millones de puestos sin
llenar casi 400.000 más que antes de la
pandemia
daniela y porque entonces edad esta
situación esta situación no solamente se
está dando en reinounido miren estados
unidos también hay récord de vacantes
los analistas lo atribuyen a que a la
gente le da miedo volver a sus trabajos
y contraer el virus oa las ayudas
gubernamentales que hacen más rentable
que se queden en la casa así como
también los altos costos
de los niños pero en este caso en reino
unido los empleadores de algunos
sectores como el de procesamiento de
alimentos y el de transporte por
carretera afirman que las restricciones
impuestas a los trabajadores de la unión
europea tras el preside les dificultan
cubrir sus puestos no vamos muy lejos
hace unos meses el gobierno de boris
johnson se vio obligado a emitir miles
de visas de trabajo temporales para
atender la crisis de conductores de
camiones cisterna que generó caos en el
país y es relativa daniela porque hay
muchos que les da miedo ir al trabajo
pero si no les da miedo dice un poco
tomarse unas cervezas con los amigos y
señor bueno vamos a hablar a los
restaurantes en grecia que amanecieron
cerrados este martes hablando de pops
oiga raúl yo no conozco a grecia pero
dicen que no es común ver restaurantes
bares y cafeterías cerrados y menos en
noviembre y contar rica que es la comida
griega así es pero este martes si lo
están a causa de la huelga convocada por
este gremio para pedir más ayudas
económicas ante la crisis derivada de la
pandemia
el gobierno griego inyectó unos 24 mil
millones de euros en 2020 otros 16 mil
millones en 2021 y 2000 900 millones
están previstos para 2022 pero los
dueños de estos negocios lo consideran
insuficiente
dicen raúl estar afectados por las
restricciones vigentes desde comienzos
de noviembre para sortear el aumento de
los casos de kobe 19 por ejemplo los no
vacunados deben presentar una prueba
negativa para poderse sentar en las
terrazas y los espacios interiores son
sólo para vacunados si no lo hacen
afrontan multas de hasta cinco mil euros
estas medidas son bastante difíciles de
cumplir con una tasa de vacunación que
no llega ni al 60% yo creo que con armas
gratis que pagar esos 5
daniela le pregunté entonces seguimos
hablando de alimentos cuál es el desafío
de los bancos de alimentos de eeuu estos
lugares ya tenían un desafío bien grande
que fue el aumento de la pandemia
durante la el aumento de la pandemia no
de la demanda durante la pandemia de
coronavirus pero ahora se suma uno nuevo
que es el aumento vertiginoso de los
precios de los alimentos y los problemas
en la cadena de suministro escuchamos
nuestros bancos de alimentos están
viendo precios que son dos o tres veces
más que hace apenas nueve meses y
quinindé gente me gusta estar en él
desde el comienzo de la pandemia vimos
un repentino e intenso aumento en la
demanda el año pasado estimamos que 60
millones de personas accedieron al
sistema de alimentos benéficos en este
país hasta este mes contra cáncer de
colon vengo aquí porque necesito comida
para mi familia sabes por qué porque en
las tiendas todo es muy caro la comida
todo y mi dinero no es suficiente mamani
es no era le pregunto de los factores
que originan esta crisis daniela bueno
es toda una lista raúl pero la cadena de
suministros está interrumpida y este es
el primer factor también hay menos
inventario y menos mano de obra y los
alimentos donados pues son más caros de
transportar por culpa de esto eso se
traduce en que las familias están
obteniendo raciones más pequeñas o les
están sustituyendo alimentos básicos
como la muy preciada mantequilla de maní
que hoy cuesta casi el doble que hace un
año y lo que más preocupa hoy por hoy es
que se acercan los días clave como el
día de acción de gracias y la navidad
por ejemplo una caja de cinco libras de
pollos congelados para navidad ha subido
más del 10 por ciento el pavo también ha
subido qué delicia un sándwich con
mantequilla de maní le gusta no me gustó
aún no uses pasamos ahora llevamos con
indicadores económicos bueno pues la
mayoría de los mercados subieron este
martes a medida que los inversionistas
se sintieron animados por las
conversaciones entre el xi jingping y
joe biden por la misma razón en europa
varios índices tocaron máximos
históricos a media marcha también a la
esperada declaraciones del banco central
europeo dan y gracias entonces por toda
la información económica nos vemos
mañana con más economía y no le va a
traer entonces de undoc sánduche de
mantequilla de maní quería declarar
mañana para que para que lo probará
gracias daniela entonces muchísimas
gracias mañana con más economía nosotros
vamos directo a parís